the question today is is the chinese
economy close to experiencing a huge
economic and financial crisis could the
so-called chinese model collapse
[Music]
visualpolitik community as recently as
2020 the chinese government was
promising widespread contentment the
country had faced the trade war
unleashed by donald trump and was one of
the first countries to contain the sars
coronavirus ii pandemic even despite
being the source of the pandemic the
chinese economy had one of the best
performances in the world since then
however things have changed almost
completely take a look
22nd of july 2022 china growth slows
sharply putting gdp target out of reach
during the second quarter of 2022 the
chinese economy barely grew by 0.4
percent with the exception of the
coronavirus era it was the worst figure
in the last 30 years and put the 5.5
growth target that xi jinping's
government had set for the whole year in
danger
[Music]
forget everything you remember about
china's successes because now the
scenario is completely different since
the second half of 2021 a kind of
economic whirlwind has been brewing
within the asian giant youth
unemployment is on the verge of
surpassing the 20 mark retail activity
has slowed to the point that in real
terms retail sales are negative housing
prices have been falling since the
summer of 2021 and to top it all off as
you can see on the screen capital flight
from the country has skyrocketed eating
into much of the country's enormous
trade surplus
china is in trouble that's due to the
strong dollar and foreign investors
looking at china in a new light after
russia's invasion of ukraine robin
brooks chief economist at the institute
of international finance even the growth
of what has been one of the crown jewels
of the chinese economy has become
volatile check it out
in fact giants such as alibaba tencent
and didi among many others are carrying
out huge number of layoffs partly
because of the bad economic period and
partly because of the pressure exerted
by beijing on these companies has
damaged their profitability
china's big tech firms are axing
thousands of jobs the fact that this
scenario has forced the government to
ask large public companies and the state
apparatus itself to hire more young
people so that things do not get out of
control but that seems like a feast
today and a famine tomorrow situation
perhaps the only good news for the
chinese economy during the first half of
2022 was that despite everything foreign
direct investment increased strongly but
as you could see there is much more
negative data than positive data so the
question is just how bad is the economy
faring why do things look so concerning
how close are we to a possible collapse
what does xi jinping intend to do to
prevent china from suffering its first
major crisis in more than 50 years well
let's get into it
[Music]
how far do the problems extend
going against the grain of the rest of
the world in mid-august 2022 the
people's bank of china decided to cut
interest rates 15th of august 2022 china
shocks with rate cut as data shows
alarming slowdown not only that but at
the same time the government announced
an increase in public spending wait a
minute lower rates and more government
spending this means that the chinese
government is behaving as if the country
were already in crisis or even a
recession which is also what the data we
are coming to recognize are telling us
it is not easy to know precisely what is
going on in china we are not exactly
talking about the most transparent
country in the world however the
situation seems even worse than what the
government's estimated gdp growth
reflects but of course we are talking
about china a country that officially
has not experienced negative growth
neither after the tiananmen square
massacre nor in the asian financial
crisis of 1997 nor in 2007. so the fact
that china has published practically its
worst growth figure in the last 30 years
tells us a lot about how things are
going not exactly swimmingly but how far
do china's problems really go what are
the biggest holes in the chinese economy
today well pay close attention because
these are the five major problems today
that complicate the economic future of
this country and the possible response
of the government to try to reverse the
bad data we have seen
the first of these has a lot to do with
the very basic workings of the chinese
economy you see while in most parts of
the world gdp is a measure of what has
been produced in a country over a period
of time in the case of china it's
somewhat different yes gdp measures
exactly the same thing but the
difference is that it is a politically
determined indicator set in advance that
is the government sets a growth target
and then pushes all public and private
players to try to achieve it this is the
direct effect of planning
and you may wonder so where is the
problem basically when officials believe
that this growth is not going to be
achieved they pull out all kinds of
tricks and measures to try to achieve it
for example they throw themselves like
crazy into building infrastructure and
all kinds of large projects they make
public companies start hiring as if
there were no tomorrow and they expand
credit without breaks so that for
example families buy more and more
houses and this boosts growth everything
in order to achieve the annual goal to
top it off the vast majority of the
banking sector in china is public that
is it works to meet the government's
objectives and if more growth is needed
they go crazy granting new credit even
if their credit is given to people or
companies with doubtful payment capacity
it doesn't matter they have to meet the
credit granting target set by the state
so that these in turn help to achieve
the growth targets do you see where the
problem lies
in any case for years this was not
strictly a problem because china was
under invested it had little
infrastructure few companies and a
housing shortage so everything that was
done was tremendously productive however
since about 10 to 15 years ago the
situation has changed completely china
has built so much that new
infrastructure for example or the
expansion of state-owned enterprises
capacity is no longer profitable in
other words they do not generate
sufficient returns to compensate for all
the investment made the result a huge
debt spiral take a look debt in china
has grown so much that between the years
2007 and 2017 alone it increased
fourfold an increase greater than that
of any other country in fact today in
terms of gdp the chinese have more debt
circulating than the united states
itself and you know what this brings us
directly to the second problem
while debt has grown a lot productivity
which in the end is what largely
determines the ability to pay those
debts has plummeted this means that
china has to invest many many resources
to maintain growth investment that is
financed with debt and yet generates
little return and visualpolitik
community what happens when your debt
skyrockets your ability to pay is
reduced and on top of that your economy
goes into crisis and you lose income
well you have a problem and above all
your banks have a serious problem why
because many of your loans may go into
default that is the debtors may not be
able to pay them this is the third major
risk the third major problem facing the
chinese economy the possibility of a
huge financial crisis however we will
cover this matter very soon and with all
the details in an upcoming video so stay
tuned and if you don't follow
visualpolitik yet then don't forget to
subscribe and click on that little bell
so that you keep up to date with all of
our news well then in addition there is
a fourth major issue that is closely
related to the third one and to
everything we have already mentioned the
implosion the bursting of the real
estate market
this is a market that is simply gigantic
to give you an idea in 2021 alone 2.4
trillion dollars of new housing was sold
in china that's trillions with a t
directly and indirectly this sector
accounts for almost 30 percent of the
entire chinese economy so it's really no
joke we are talking about one of the
main economic drivers of the asian giant
well since the summer of 2021 things in
this sector have been going from bad to
worse and investment and housing sales
and prices are plummeting
15th of august 2020 ticking time bomb
china's real estate bus deepens as
housing prices fall for the 11th
straight month and that's not all
capital economics a london-based
consultancy firm notes that by the end
of 2021 in china there were
approximately 30 million unsold
properties and about 100 million more
that were sold but unoccupied
[Music]
and obviously assuming such a large part
of the chinese economy the bursting of
the real estate sector is something that
could be potentially very serious for
the chinese economy the collapse of this
industry could lead to hundreds of
thousands millions of unemployed the
collapse of many property developers
many more problems for the banks and a
general impoverishment of the chinese
due to the loss of value of their
properties remember that houses form the
largest part of the wealth of families
in this country and if house prizes fall
then suddenly these families with huge
mortgages behind them become instantly
much poorer the situation is so delicate
that videos like this one have gone
viral on chinese networks check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
of course there doesn't seem to be any
room for that to happen and it doesn't
seem advisable
but moving on the fifth problem lying
ahead for china has a lot to do with the
war in ukraine
[Music]
you see the trade war initiated by
donald trump and beijing's growing
belligerence set off alarm bells for
many companies now the russian invasion
of ukraine and the chinese government's
coveted zero policy have once again put
the geopolitical risk and the importance
of securing supply chains back on the
table this may cause many multinationals
to relocate part of their operations or
at least concentrate their new
investment outside china over the next
few years this has not yet happened but
companies are known to be concerned so
if foreign companies investment in this
country is ultimately curbed this could
be a serious blow to china's economic
growth in other words it could seriously
hamper recovery to make matters worse in
the immediate term the international
energy crisis could end up causing a
drop in chinese exports that could
further aggravate the economic problems
this giant already faces
[Music]
and then finally although it is not
something that is going to have
consequences in the immediate future but
in the medium and long term we do have
to take into account the demographic
issue
china is aging at full speed in fact it
is very likely that the working age
population is already shrinking which is
exactly what will continue to happen to
the country's population over the next
few years in the same vein in 2021 the
birth rate in china fell to an all-time
low obviously a smaller and older
population will translate into more
public spending less economic dynamism
and higher debt per capita well the fact
is that these five major problems or six
if we include the demographic decline
could be a serious headwind for china's
economic flight if not well managed they
may even end up causing a serious
economic and financial crisis in china
so the question is is the so-called
chinese model in danger of collapsing
and perhaps the most important question
right now what on earth does xi
jinping's government intend to do to
reverse this situation well let's take a
look
[Music]
the great failure of xi jinping
okay i know what many of you are
thinking let's see josh all countries
experience economic monetary and
financial crises at one time or another
from the united states to the european
union to japan to south korea and let's
not get started on latin america so
isn't it a bit of an exaggeration to
talk about the possible collapse of the
chinese model because a few economic
indicators are not going well well yes
and at the same time no
[Music]
for decades the chinese model has
consisted of guaranteeing a rapid
improvement in living standards in
exchange for the chinese not questioning
the government and the power of the
communist party let's say it has been
something like a kind of tacit unwritten
agreement that has legitimized chinese
governments and it was this way during
the terms of deng xiaoping zhang zemin
to achieve this the opening up and
integration of china into the global
economy was essential however things
have changed and are still changing
under xi jinping since the current
leader took the helm in 2012 the
government began to intervene more in
the economy growth has slowed and also
in an attempt to maintain higher growth
rates corporate household and public
sector debt has multiplied
in this way the figures have gradually
deteriorated and while yes china has
many strengths the truth is that the
explosive prosperity that has
characterized this country for years has
disappeared xi jinping cares much more
about the social political and economic
control of the communist party than the
level of prosperity so let's say that
with him china is slowing down it's
opening up it is even becoming once
again more totalitarian with all the
consequences that that entails but be
that as it may the question now is what
on earth does the chinese government
intend to do to avoid the crisis
well probably the same old formulas the
problem is at this time they may not be
enough on the one hand to avoid crises
the chinese government has always
resorted to fiscal stimulus and above
all monetary stimulus that is expanding
public spending and greatly increasing
the granting of credit do you remember
that china lowered interest rates well
exactly that they have also approved
large lines of credit for businesses and
are lowering the requirements for buying
homes in the past this has worked
however it was done at the cost of
increasing outstanding debt by a lot and
now the debt seems too large for these
policies to have much traction in fact
over the last few months the money
supply has grown much faster than the
stock of credit what's more lowering
rates when the federal reserve is doing
exactly the opposite could increase
capital outflows from the country
[Music]
then on the other hand president xi
jinping has called for an effort by all
public players to increase spending on
infrastructure so that it can become a
kind of economic cushion against the
slowdown in the real estate sector
14th of july 2022 china readies 1.1
trillion dollars to support g's
infrastructure push wait a minute though
because it's not that simple why because
one of the main sources of financing for
the local and regional governments is
the sale of land and revenues from the
real estate sector and guess what land
sales have dropped 30
in 12 months this is what explains why
these governments have started 2022
issuing debt at a record pace to finance
all kinds of infrastructure such as
industrial parks transportation networks
water projects mobile networks and data
centers which brings us directly back to
the problem we saw earlier xi jinping is
trying to maintain china's economic
growth by issuing debt and building
infrastructure that is not profitable
because most of it is not needed and
since it is not profitable once the
projects are finished they no longer
contribute to economic growth but the
debt and the interest remain
in short china may still have many
strengths and many sectors that are
going from strength to strength however
its overall situation has been
deteriorating sharply over the past few
years now the country seems on the verge
of facing an economic and perhaps
financial crisis and it is not at all
clear how the government expects to deal
with it because as you've seen the usual
formulas may not work this time could
this mean that the era of great chinese
growth has come to an end well more and
more analysts are pointing to this
possibility all in all perhaps the
biggest problem is that xi jinping wants
to compensate for the worsening economic
performance with a much more aggressive
nationalism and that that would be bad
for everyone but having reached this
point it's your turn do you think china
will end up plunging into a severe
economic crisis or on the contrary do
you think it will manage to overcome all
of its problems do you think the
so-called chinese model could collapse
what will xi jinping do to face all of
these problems as always leave us your
comments below and give us a like if you
found this video interesting thank you
so very very much for watching all the
best and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you